[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 28th of
april i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
a torrey mp has been accused of watching
pornography in the house of commons it
comes as another tory said that angela
raynor was trying to distract boris
johnson at pmqs by crossing and
uncrossing her legs james forsyth the
spectator's political editor and katie
balls our deputy political editor will
join me to discuss the culture of the
commons douglas murray writes this
week's cover piece fractured he says
that western culture is under its most
serious attack since the cold war with a
woke minority quote destroying ties that
bind the west he'll discuss it with
fraser nelson elon musk has bought
twitter this week for 44 billion dollars
fraser in this week's magazine asks
whether having the world's richest man
in charge of the social media site could
make it the home of free speech on the
internet he'll join the show with
suzanne nozzle florida governor ron
desantis has been picking a fight with
disney after they oppose his now dubbed
don't say gay bill did he go too far is
he tapping into what voters want is it
both freddie gray will join the show
alongside charlie cook and finally i
went on a course at the london zoo to
overcome my severe arachnophobia and i'm
delighted to say it worked i'll be
joined by dave clark who led the program
to explain how he did it
but before we get going a quick reminder
to subscribe to the spectator you can
get 12 issues of the magazine for just
12 pounds and we'll even give you a free
20 pound amazon voucher too you can find
the offer at spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
a conservative mp has been accused of
watching porn in the house of commons
that emerged yesterday at the weekend
too another tory commented that angela
raynor labor's deputy leader was
crossing and on crossing her legs to
distract the prime minister at pmqs
what's going wrong in the commons
to discuss i'm joined by james forsyth
our political editor and katie balls our
deputy political editor
katie james thanks for joining me on
spectator tv
katie first i want to start on the most
recent story that an mp has been accused
of watching pornography in the house of
commons it sounds pretty shocking can
you tell us what's happened and explain
what the fallout has been
yes this came from a meeting where mps
were discussing sexism and politics and
empathy started sharing stories and that
story included an mp saying that they
had once seen their colleague watching
porn in the commons chamber now when
this first started emerged there was
some some online saying this is a front
venture um ultimately you don't know who
it is but i think since uh that that was
aired the senses that this is a tory mp
isn't it's not being suggested this is
someone who does hold a government role
and but the question is now who is doing
that and
and we're hearing that obviously the
chief whip is keen to investigate this
uh you were hearing from you know senior
conservatives that whoever has done this
ought to be punished um but the question
is are we actually gonna find out who it
is and i think unless uh those people
who come forward who were discussing
this more in an anonymous way of you
know describing their experience of
sexism in parliament unless i want to
come out and specifically name them it's
very hard to take this on further
james how serious of an offense would
this be seen to be i think it is very
serious i mean i think i mean watching
pornography in the workplace is is
clearly a uh wrong i i and but i think
to watch it in the commons chamber is
such an affront uh you know this is the
cockpit of our democracy
uh that is such an act of disrespect and
i think it's also uh it's such a kind of
voyeuristic act because you would know
because of the way the commons chamber
is set up but other people might see
what you're what you are watching that
it is it's kind of almost also an act of
intimidation at the same time as well as
being pathetic
and so i think it's very very hard to
see how whoever was doing this uh could
remain either in uh in the conservative
parliamentary party or frankly as an mp
at all
katie this comes after the mail on
sunday reported at the weekend that a
tory mp was saying that labor's deputy
leader angela raynor was deliberately
crossing and uncrossing her legs in an
attempt to quote distract boris johnson
at pmqs the comments have been widely
condemned how bad is all of this for the
conservative party in their image
so there's a wider issue which has been
happening in recent months and if you
look at tory mps backbench mps um there
have been a know spate of stories which
have suggested tori's behaving badly and
that is a conviction or um for example
in the recent case of an mp where they
were caught um
and what they claimed was a sting but
ultimately um taking cocaine and and
also um propositioning um parliamentary
staffers and i think that therefore this
is building up and you're seeing
opposition try to say this too until mrs
sleazes back narrative and i have to say
i've heard members of the 2019 intake so
they are worried that is getting back to
almost the major years in in terms of
that sleaze and how it looks to the
outside world
james this is the return of pestminster
yeah i think it is me too too as someone
said to me yesterday i think there's
also another thing going on here which
is parliament it is back to normal in
terms of a social side really for the
first time since covet and i was talking
to one kind of long-standing tory mp
he's always long taking a kind of
pastoral interest in his colleagues and
he was saying that one of the mistakes
that's been made
he thinks is that no one has taken aside
the new intake of mps to say look you
know there is lots you know the
weather's getting better people are back
in westminster the terrace is open but
take it easy it's not healthy to be out
there every night drinking heavily uh
and that no no one has taken these
people aside and they argue that the
terrorists is is is is
what caused this whole angelarena story
which was obviously
crass in the extreme
and bad manners uh and and i think this
is a worry i think the worry among
tories is that this kind of japanese
knotweed of sleaze is back and now every
story that comes out is seen through
this now i mean this is it's also worth
saying that you know there's an
accusation about
things that a member of the shadow
cabinet has said you know that this
problem is not
is not uh confined to one party but i
think there is i think that i think it
is
really does risk for the tories feeling
like a kind of sense of decay akin to
92-97
james let's turn to your politics column
this week for the magazine you write
that after months of good relations
between the eu and the uk things could
soon turn rocky again give us the
details yeah so i think the russian
invasion of ukraine reminded the uk and
the eu of the need for the kind of
world's democracies to work together
that ultimately they were strategic
allies and partners uh rather than
rivals i think what is going to make
things rocky is that in the queen speech
boris johnson intends to propose to
legislate to protect the good friday
agreement in its entirety what this is
code for
is essentially the uk unilaterally
overriding parts of the northern ireland
protocol if it can't reach
an agreement with the eu now
this is a kind of classic boris johnson
negotiating tactic with the eu he puts a
threat on the table think back to the
internal market bill and sees whether
that gets the eu to move its position i
think the uk government feels frustrated
that at the moment all the eu will do is
have a kind of technical negotiation
with it on the northern ireland protocol
uh on the basis that the uk signed this
document just a couple of years ago
while as the uk wants a more
fundamental uh negotiation about the
nature of the protocol
i think that the i think some in the uk
government think that the best chance
for progress is that you know there is
this whole question of how are you going
to get the devolved institutions of
northern ireland back up and running
after the may elections i mean that's
particularly the case if sinn fein are
the largest party and gets nominated
first minister i think the dep would not
be keen to serve uh in
an executive where there is a shin pain
first minister to put it mildly and so i
think some of the uk government argue
that you know only by addressing
unionist concerns about the protocol can
you really put pressure on the dup to go
into the executive and get the
institutions back up and running
and katie finally you
have written about foreign secretary liz
truss's mansion speech this week the
foreign secretary said that russia needs
to be pushed out of quote the whole of
ukraine this comes after russia has
sanctioned
287 mps can you talk us through trust's
thinking
yes so this is uh the foreign
secretary's big keynote to set out her
vision for foreign policy and i think
there's you can lick it in two ways so
there's the immediate and then there's
more long term so in terms of ukraine i
think as you've just touched on um it
was another ramping up for the rhetoric
when it comes to russia and i think
we're we're far past the point now where
you were
where were a few weeks ago where there
was still some in government he would
talk about potential peace talks
and um there's trust making the point
that russia needs to leave all the
ukraine uh the defense secretary ben
wallace backing her up this morning on
the media round and when it was put to
him does that involve you know places
that russia went to before this year so
outside of the most recent uh full-scale
invasion so crimea and others then it
was just that that is the position um
now this suggests and it seems i think
the foreign secretary's expectation is
that we're heading for potentially a
very long war in ukraine and sometimes
you know five ten years um whereas
where would this end and there is no
easy end in sight right now and i think
more generally in terms of uh what liz
trust wants to do in terms of uk foreign
policy is actually bringing more of an
economic underpinning to it so
we saw in the integrated review that um
russia was correctly identified as the
most you know hostile and then china was
also named as a as a country that you'd
have to grapple with and but then to now
in order to bring other countries into
the uk's orbit into the orbit the west
and this effort to do that free trade
and also doing that with countries that
don't necessarily fall into the
definition of a liberal democracy and so
you don't work for aggressors that's
where in this carrot sticker phrase the
stick comes through sanctions but
actually a carrot for those countries
which are
you know not currently key allies but
have the potential and in by bringing
them in you also deprive the aggressors
of working them is what they are hoping
to do
katie james thanks for joining me
in this week's cover story douglas
murray asks whether or not the west can
fix itself why should the west he says
axo ashamed douglas spoke to fraser
nelson yesterday
douglas in your cover story and in your
book you talk about a war on the west
what kind of shape is that war taking
in my view what's happening is a
vicious unrelenting remorseless attack
on everything that constitutes the west
as we know it uh the west's history the
peoples of the west the culture of the
west all the institutions of the west
the traditions of the west
uh and this is this has been growing for
quite a long time now you could argue
it's been growing for the best part of
at least half a century and then it has
sped up massively in the last few years
and as i say in my cover story in the
spectator this week
one of the most visible things is this
war on the history of the west the war
on the history of a country like britain
so that you know every single one of our
institutions from
kew gardens to
um
the national trust
to the tate to the british library to um
the globe theater all seem to be all the
things that are meant to be effectively
custodians of our history have actually
started to wage a war on that history so
that they present our history as if
there's just nothing good about it and
as i say in my cover piece one of the
many devastating things about this is
that a country and a culture and a
society can only be held together if
first of all it has some agreement on
its past and secondly
it thinks that past is broadly good
because if you don't think you were good
in the past why would you do anything in
the present right but is this so much
different to what we had during the cold
war for example i mean and america was
hugely divided to come i remember seeing
some figures recently about how many
domestic bombings there were in america
in a typical year in the 1960s in
britain you had full-on communist
parties in america youth communist
parties in britain who were making um
absolutely devastating critiques uh well
not very effective but they were you
know very much at war with capitalism
with the basics of today
is it really yeah but now we've just got
a few students pulling down statues i
mean is it really worse
well it started with students and as
andrew sullivan famously said it's built
out and now we all live on campus
it's now gone through every corporation
every government department it isn't
just a few students anymore there was a
time when you could argue that it was
but the students left university and
they and they went right out into the
marketplace and they had jobs to go to
you know one of the jokes on
conservatives in recent years was that
conservatives often joked in the last
generation these people doing these
ridiculous degrees they're going to go
out into the real world they'll discover
there aren't any jobs for them the
market will assert itself flat out wrong
the joke was on us there were plenty of
jobs for these people to go on into they
went into hr departments they they went
into the civil service they were the
ones who passed the civil services
demand that for any public appointment
any civil service appointment you have
to demonstrate a belief in and and
devotion to diversity inclusion equity
all things which are in their
fundamentals as i say in the piece
western you cannot dedicate yourself to
this new pseudo-ideological pseudo
religion because in part everything
about it is against the institutions and
the history of what the country used to
believe in until yesterday so you know
the big difference between now and the
cold war was first of all in the cold
war there was some unity because there
was some recognition of a shared foe but
secondly there were still adults there
were still adults in the room willing to
stand up for traditions willing to stand
up for history willing to say that
actually we have virtues as a country
and not just vices virtues as a people
not just vices things that we did well
in our history not just things we did
ill and today look around the public
square
all of the adults fled the scene
every corporation in britain every
government department every publishing
house everybody sees the same thing the
people you describe as the sort of
highly ideological students make all of
the running the shouting the desecration
of the past and the adults give in
effectively what we are living through
now in britain and then the wider west
is a cultural revolution and it's a
cultural revolution where the adults
have been intimidated into either
silence or going along with it
but douglas you say there was a common
enemy in the cold war but we're getting
one now aren't we since putin's invasion
of ukraine there has been a strikingly
coherent and as far as i can work out
spontaneous response from europe and
america and beyond into presenting a
united front against him
well
it's a very important point you just
made
the russian invasion of ukraine seems to
some extent to have have fortified
certain people it seems to have
clarified the minds of some people it's
answered the 30 year old question that
we all asked of wither nato what's the
point of nato that question isn't being
asked anymore when sweden and other
countries join nato later this year that
will be a very interesting answer in
itself but
here is the problem it's not just
putin's russia in the 21st century that
poses a threat a far bigger threat a far
bigger challenge in the 21st century is
china the communist party of china which
as i mentioned in the book is the only
country in the world putin's russia is a
basket case it was even before this war
especially is after it the only country
in the 21st century likely to catch up
with and then supersede america and the
western nations as the global power the
most important economy in the world is
china led by the chinese communist party
and that pumps out anti-western
propaganda all the time just this past
week the china daily news one of the
organs of the chinese communist party um
pumped out a vision of uncle sam behind
the oval office desk and a pile of
corpses and said that america is all
about racism and and so on there's two
points to make here the first is of
course this is totally cynical i mean
ask any of the muslims in xinjiang
whether the chinese communist party
actually minds about family separations
or racism and you'd get an answer but
secondly the problem that exists now is
not chinese anti-westernism or russian
anti-westernism or or middle eastern
anti-westernism it is western
anti-westernism it is white people doing
this against white people it is white
people
deciding that our history is all a
history of racism and that we're racist
now and institutionally racist now and
somehow derek chauvin who was convicted
of the killing of george floyd is the
emblematic figure of the west and this
isn't a fringe thing you know no less a
figure than the u.s
ambassador to the un went to the un last
year and condemned her own country for
institutional racism something which by
the way the chinese communist parties
envoy to the un found incredibly useful
when he stood up to make his remarks and
said this is the first time that the
country has come to the united nations
and confessed its guilt
so the problem is not the external
challenge the problem is the internal
one the problem is people in the west
have been taught to think horribly about
the west so that our history is only a
history of repression and slavery and
colonialism our history is uniquely bad
not uniquely good here's here's the most
important point in a way and it's
something i bring across not just in the
book but in in my peaceful spectator
this week we have evidence for the fact
that this is flat out wrong how do we
know because the football proves it the
un published another study just in the
last year asking people around the world
fleeing not just conflict but economic
deprivation where do you want to go what
are your destinations people do not flee
to putin's russia they do not flee to
venezuela they do not flee to communist
china the number one destination that
people around the world want to go to is
the united states of america and britain
and canada and others follow shortly
afterwards now that says something it
says that whilst our society is being
told we have nothing to be proud of the
world wants to come here that whilst we
are being told we live in a racist
society and a bewildering array of
people want to come here and here's the
important thing about that it's not just
in the present
our present is not as it is by accident
it's come about because of our past if
there's something good in our present
it's because we must have done something
good in the past and that's what i want
people to realize and to be able to
focus on if we had to unite as a country
as a civilization as a culture we need
to recognize not just that we've done
some things well but we've be done more
things well than anybody else and it's
proved in the footfall of the people who
want to come here and one final thing
douglas isn't everything we do well
arguing with each other i mean you talk
about these divisions and this huge
cantankerousness but isn't that the sign
of a west succeeding i mean there isn't
much war institutions in north korea
right now there's not much in the way of
public debate wouldn't you expect a
successful thriving west to be
absolutely at loggerheads over culture
music history the whole gamut
absolutely and as i say in the book i
absolutely encourage that i want to shut
down no debate but currently we have had
an entirely one-sided debate in recent
years there was a time when the debate
was one-sided in the opposite direction
few generations ago if you were taught
about colonialism in british schools you
were taught only the good things um a
few generations ago if you studied
american history you might not have
known that thomas jefferson owned slaves
today it's the only thing people know
about the founding fathers in america so
here's the thing i want there to be a
rigorous debate i want there to be a
thriving debate but i do not want it to
be one-sided and the people who have
been attacking white people in recent
years and being saying racist things
about white people have been a one-sided
monotone discussion and they've got away
with it for too long the people who've
attacked our culture and all of our
heroes from winston churchill to lord
nelson these people have been doing a
one-sided attack on our history i
believe that the british public and the
wider western public have the right to
have a more honest appraisal of
ourselves and our past and that includes
the right
to have pride in our past because as it
happens it's not just vital for a
society to hold together but the facts
just happen to be on our side
douglas thank you for your appraisal and
for your cover story in this week's
magazine
and fraser joins me on the show now to
talk about elon musk's purchase of
twitter the tesla ceo made the 44
billion dollar move earlier this week
saying he wanted to restore freedom of
speech to the platform could his plan
work and our government's going to try
to stop him fraser writes about it in
this week's magazine and joining us is
suzanne nozzle ceo of pen america an
organization founded to defend and
celebrate free expression
you write for this week's magazine about
elon musk's 44 billion purchase of
twitter and what it means for broader
public policy in the uk
we will get on to that point but first
what did you make of musk's decision to
buy the social media company
um i thought it was incredible as is
much that elon musk does you can't make
much of a business case spending that
much money on twitter it's only made
profit too out of the last 10 years it's
really struggled to find much of a
future since it joined the stock market
i think it's shares have been bought for
pretty much the same price they were
floated at all those years ago but then
again elon musk is worth a quarter of a
trillion dollars somebody like him has
got the 44 billion to spend on and what
he regards as not an economic not a
business case but on he says a defense
of free speech now and if that's what he
means then great because free speech
needs a deep pocket to champion right
now and what has been happening is that
the governments or governments not just
in britain but in the european union and
other parts of the world have been
trying to suborn free speech by putting
commercial incentives in front of social
media companies which have been
following those incentives so everything
that you see from the conversation we're
having right now on youtube to articles
you may or may not come across on
facebook and twitter go through some
kind of vetting process an invisible
vetting process and more people should
know about it if they don't but elon
musk is the one saying he's had enough
of this he wants to go public on the
algorithms used to promote or to cover
up conversations and social media posts
and to bring a more democratic approach
to twitter i've got no idea exactly what
it means i don't think anybody else does
either but it's going to be very
interesting to watch suzanne what do you
make of his decision to buy twitter
it's hard to know whether this is a kind
of an ego play that he's been frustrated
with the platform and you know thinks he
could do a better job wants to
amplify his own voice and influence as a
cultural figure that seems to be
part of it he's certainly someone filled
with a lot of bravado uh you know i
think we take him at his word in terms
of being frustrated with some of the
constraints the way a platform like
twitter operates you know if he thinks
that
the answer is simply sweeping away the
rules wholesale i think he is in for
some really tough
lessons it depends in part what you
really mean by free speech it is free
speech just the ability of anybody
anywhere with any motivation and purpose
to write whatever they want on a
platform like twitter because if so
we will find ourselves with a public
square
as musk puts it that is just overridden
with harassment with trolling with
doxing with disinformation hoaxes
huckster-ism conspiracy theories you
know all of the things that drive people
away from social media and that attract
detract from the ability to engage in
reasoned discourse and so i think what
he's going to find is the struggles that
a platform like twitter has had in terms
of where to strike the balance with
removing harmful content trying to
create space for
meaningful and constructive and
enlightening and engaging conversation
trying to attract eyeballs uh
generate revenue all of that is going to
persist into a musk era i just don't see
how it uh how he avoids that
fraser on wednesday musk tweeted by free
speech i simply mean that which matches
the law i'm against censorship that goes
far beyond the law
one could argue that even there you're
starting to get little glimpses at a
climb down that goes far beyond the law
for example
and what do you make of suzanne's point
that if he were to actually implement
something that
allowed for far more hate speech for
example for far more pile-ons for far
more aggressive language that he may
actually come to regret it
well i think he is in for a difficult
decision of course you've got to draw
the line somewhere and there have been
rivals to twitter parlor and things like
that and those rivals have tended to
find out pretty quickly that it doesn't
it's not a great look when you get
genuine racists and bigots as spouting
their their hatred on these forums
nobody really wants to be part of that
so of course you need to cut out
things that are against that are
perfectly lawful pornography for example
is perfectly lawful elon musk won't be
having that on twitter of course you
will draw the line but when you do draw
the line you start to get flack you need
to defend the death for example
somebody's and that somebody's right to
say something which you absolutely
disagree with and that can be difficult
position will a tech billionaire like
musk be particularly willing to spend
his time and energy fighting these
pretty squalid battles as they are most
of the time and that's i think what we
what we need to to find out but his
distinction saying that he's again
censoring anything which is legal
brought me to thinking about the uk
government's plan because it wants to do
is to create a whole category of things
that are legal perfectly legal but still
harmful whatever harmful means and make
sure social media companies will censor
that
now this i think poses a grave risk to
freedom of speech in britain and if you
say to social media companies and tell
people like elon musk we want you to
censor things that are perfectly legal
but we might regard them as harmful and
by the way if you get this wrong we're
going to find you up to 10 of your
global revenue that's billions of
dollars
so it would take somebody of elon musk's
character to run that risk to say you
know what i'm going to let people say
what they like about the government and
and if that means i fulfill the
regulator then so be it because most
companies if they're running their
company for profit as um certainly mark
zuckerberg is he doesn't really care
about free speech he just wants to make
lots of money mainly from showing you
know gossip or videos of cats playing
the piano or what have you i mean the
advertising revenue is what keeps these
companies going um but if elon musk is
prepared to take a financial hit and
stand up to the british government when
it seeks to usher in this new era of
censorship that's something that i would
welcome although i have my doubts as to
whether he could even musk could really
care too much about nadine doris and
what she intends to
censor or even worse and the real
problem here is the decisions that were
not seen for example take on this
spectator tv this is made thanks to
youtube if it wasn't for youtube's
technology we wouldn't have a product
but youtube itself has got a list of
things that are legal to say but it will
not tolerate one of those things for
example is to say that there is some
voting malfunction which made a swing
states go the wrong way in the 2016
election if you say what i have just
said and then do not follow it up with
by the way that's wrong or by the way
that's contentious then youtube will
come along and center you and take you
off the air now we only know about that
because that's a rare example of a
youtube kind of um
free speech um exemption clause that
we're aware of there are so many other
things like that sentences that if you
say them you will be removed from the
internet what we need is greater
transparency as to what these are
because you run the risk pretty quickly
of having political debates skewed one
way or another and government critics
silenced that is the problem that we're
facing with the online safety bill and
we need a lot more elon musks to protect
us from that risk suzanne i'm interested
in this idea that fraser brings up about
providing blanket protection um which in
this case is being given by a
billionaire to ordinary folk who want to
be able to say what they want to say on
the internet i mean it could be the case
that elon musk doesn't bog himself down
in dramatically changing the algorithms
of twitter or trying to change
nitty-gritty regulation but more or less
just says i'm going to push back
publicly when politicians want to crack
down on social media and that in and of
itself could create change do you think
he's going to be more of a technocrat
when it comes to this or do you think
he's going to be more public simply
pushing back on this idea that speech
should be censored
now my guess from what we've seen of him
is he'll do a bit of both he likes to
use the bully pulpit i i wouldn't be
surprised if he
tries to goad and provoke politicians
and regulators as they wade into
this realm if he that he sounds off on
his views on particular pieces of
regulation or what he sees as
overzealousness on the part of for
example eu authorities or
legislators in washington who are
contemplating
some similar uh kinds of bills and
measures so i expect him to be part of
that debate but i think the real test
and what we should hold him to is what
he does himself with the platform you
know how far is he going to go in terms
of trying to really protect speech one
thing he could do
very concretely for example is augment
the appeals process on twitter right now
uh if your content is taken down or your
account is disabled you know it can you
may not get a clear answer as to why
that happened what rule you're accused
of breaking if you believe that the
determination was an error the appeals
processes are cumbersome they can take
weeks we all know the value of twitter
lies in the immediacy the ability to get
your views out in real time to respond
to something that's breaking news and so
you know what is must going to invest in
augmenting those systems so that where
content moderation
systems are overzealous where there are
false positives those free speech rights
can be vindicated in real time that's
something concrete that he could do
you know when it comes to online
harassment that is an impairment of
freedom of expression when people are
driven off twitter because the
environment becomes so
toxic and victorious and threatening
that they feel unsafe is he going to
take steps to address that on the
platform to give users the tools that
they need to protect themselves and to
continue to make their voices heard and
to exercise their freedom of expression
so those are things that when he takes
over this platform are going to be in
his immediate hands and under his
control and i think we need to look very
carefully at how he's going to approach
that to push him hard to make good on
what he is promising if he is a champion
of free speech you know there are ways
to realize that very concretely on
twitter and uh you know that's what i
hope we see from elon musk and if he
falls short i think it's it's the
imperative of civil society of twitter
users to hold him accountable
fraser i want to go back to the online
safety bill that uh you were mentioning
before it sounds innocuous but you say
in this week's article that it will be
one of the most ambitious censorship
laws the world has ever seen
it seems like at the moment there's a
very real chance that this is going to
pass through parliament can you tell us
what that will mean for free speech in
the uk
well
what it will mean is that there will be
a new test harmful that if any online
company publishes what a regulator might
regard as harmful they will get fined so
what you will then get is automatic
sensitive which happens already by the
way everything we say here on youtube
everything which is um put out on
twitter or facebook is scanned by bots
there's simply too much of it to scan
for humans to scan and there will be
algorithms deciding if the subject
matter is a bit too risky now
in theory of course this will stop
promotion of terrorism and drug
promotion etc that's illegal
what we will and i is an editor and come
up against all the time
minority arguments which we're making
which are falling foul of these sensors
for example we commissioned two
academics to look at the science on face
mask usage two academics very respected
in their field and facebook decided this
went against the government line and it
slapped an information a label on it
saying that this was untrue information
now facebook will not respond to our
emails asking
asking why this is untrue and this is
the kind of um material which could end
up maybe not even published at all
because somebody perhaps a computer
perhaps a human we just don't know has
looked to something has judged it to be
risky because during covent going
against the government's line on
lockdown and other things was risky and
we think you know what we're not going
to take the risk we're going to either
put a label on it saying it's untrue or
has happened to david davis mp when he
made a speech against lockdown that was
removed completely from youtube now that
was a human error it caused uproar but
that's an example of the mistakes which
will be taken all the time now we've
also seen navarra media which is a very
successful and the far left
political organization which exists on
youtube they were taken down for a while
again by a mistake there was uproar they
were taken back up we went to the
socialist workers party their page was
taken down from facebook again in error
but those are the kinds of things we can
expect to happen a lot more regularly
but we won't know when the decisions are
being happened we only know about the
ones where there is abroad because it is
visible what happens if your average
citizen wants to make points critical of
lockdown policy critical of the
government or saying things which at
censor or a bot might regard as um
disfavoring whatever government
regulatory regime there is they will
simply and not appear so you're going to
get what appears to be a facebook news
feed which is you think you're getting
what all your friends are posting in
fact what you're getting is a curated
version of that curated by a politicized
formula and the government will be
calling the shots now for three
centuries in britain we have stopped
government calling the shots over press
regulation magazine's newspapers have
fought successfully to defend their
independence and that's for basic
democratic reasons you do not want to
have a media where the government sits
at the top regulating it but that's
exactly what we're getting with digital
when the online safety bill has come
across along when you're going to get
the online world operating under an
apparatus decided by politicians with
judge with judgments made me by a
government-appointed regulator a
regulator who can himself be overruled
by the government i'm not a fan of
political control with free speech i
think we've fought for a long time to
prevent it but britain is the first
country to sleepwalk into it and i think
the repercussions are going to be pretty
big especially when regimes like turkey
see what we've done here and replicate
it over there we're about to lose
something very precious i think and it's
quite depressing to think that
characters like elon musk might be our
only hope of defense
ron desantis the governor of florida has
found himself in a fight with disney
when desantis introduced legislation
that would limit what young kids would
be taught about sex and gender the
corporation announced that it would push
for the law to be repealed or struck
down in the courts desantis hit back
we're sending a special tax status that
disney's orlando resort has had for the
past 50 years
is he going too far i'm joined now by
freddie gray the spectator's deputy
editor and charlie cook a senior writer
at the national review magazine
freddie you write for this week's
magazine about florida governor ron
desantis fight with disney can you break
down exactly what's happened for
spectator tv viewers
well it's quite a twisty tourney's story
but uh i'll i'll do my best um i think
it speaks to
a growing phenomenon in america which is
uh if you want woke corporate america
uh fighting against republican and quite
hardened
uh bruiser republican governors and
legislators
and the disney story is a very good
example of this uh and to understand it
you have to go back to
the
so-called don't say gay bill
which was a bill introduced by ron
desantis which essentially was very fair
and sensible and i think i can say that
neutrally because all it did was
ensure
parents had more authority over teachers
over what their children are taught
about sex and gender
and desantis picked this issue cleverly
because it sent uh progressives into a
sort of frenzy a real uh
fit of apoplexy
and disney was dragged into this because
the former ceo
of disney bob iger
uh decided to tweet
and go on cnn about it and say that it
was outrageous and he forced the current
ceo bob chapek
to issue a statement saying that disney
will do what it can
to fight uh this build this this bill
that this law that had actually passed
and so ron desantis took that as an act
of aggression and he responded charlie
can correct me if i'm getting this wrong
and he responded by uh
passing a law
with withdrawing disney's special state
special district status in florida
and that is a special district status
that there are lots of them all over
america but it meant that this enormous
disney world in near orlando
in florida had its
tax status
withdrawn or might have its tax data
withdrawn and disney saves millions of
dollars every year through this special
district
and it may have to pay millions in tax
and lose lots of special privileges as a
real result of this special district
status
so i hope that that's not too uh twisty
but that was the fight and it's a very
sort of interesting fight because it
explic it speaks to what happens when
increasingly aggressive radical
republican
politicians on the right get into fights
with corporate america and how that
plays into politics is really
interesting and it's causing divisions
on the right which i think charlie can
tell us more about
charlie first do you agree or disagree
with freddie's analysis of the don't say
gay bill and that it's fair and neutral
what he described and second what did
you make of what ron desantis has
decided to do with disney
so yes i like the bill uh don't say gay
as a pejorative way of describing it an
inaccurate way of describing it that a
lot of
um
left-wing agitators have used and
succeeded in in using i mean this is now
the standard way that the bill is talked
about in the press
um it doesn't of course say anything of
the sort uh if it did i would oppose it
and what it says is that
the instruction for children in public
schools in florida uh between
k kindergarten and third grade we're
talking very young here five six seven
um
must be age appropriate
and you know this is an attempt to push
back against some of the real attempts
to include in curricular gender ideology
um you know critics have said well
it will stop a teacher who is gay and
married to someone of the same sex from
mentioning their husband or their wife
it doesn't and the guidelines that
florida put out show that it doesn't and
that's why it's very popular
um it's popular not only among uh
floridians it's popular among democrats
in florida uh democrat primary voters in
florida some of the most politically
engaged so
um
this law
should not have been as controversial as
it has been and one of the reasons that
it has been is it's just been
misdescribed just happens a lot in in
politics obviously um
my objection is is to this secondary
move um you know i've got a lot of
emails from people on the right who've
said why don't you want to fight why do
you hate ron desantis i don't i'm a
conservative i live in florida i voted
for desantis i will vote for him again
now he's actually been on a remarkable
winning streak he signed a 15-week
abortion ban into law ahead of potential
overturn of roe v wade um he
in my view got covered pretty much
exactly right he signed this bill the
parental rights and education bill and
then told its critics to pound sand
um it's just that this secondary move
against disney has two big problems
first off it's very clearly retaliatory
you shouldn't make law like this
disney's allowed to speak up even if
disney's wrong
and pretending that this was some
long-standing policy objective is
preposterous i mean no republican in
florida had even thought about this
until about a week ago rescinding this
50-year
policy that has worked
secondly i just think it's a bad idea on
policy grounds um
the way that this has been demagogued is
that this is some special treatment for
disney
but it's not really it's a way of
dealing with what is an extremely
peculiar setup disney world is the size
of san francisco it's twice the size of
manhattan there's 175 miles of roads
inside it it has 44 000 hotel rooms this
isn't sea world or universal studios or
you know alton towers this is
essentially a city
and florida has done this for a lot of
strange uh peculiar or unusual entities
like orlando airport is an independent
special district the villages is
sprawling retirement community is an
independent special district the daytona
international speedway is one because
sometimes you just have to set up odd
rules for for odd entities and i think
desantis hasn't thought this through i
think what he's done is possibly illegal
and if it's not illegal it's just going
to take years to untangle for no
discernible reason
yeah freddie on that point i mean almost
regardless of whether or not you support
this bill something does not sit right
with the idea of government essentially
using its heavy fists to come down on a
company that has disagreed with it and
it's disagreed with it for you know you
and charlie have put forward the
argument for the bill i'll put forward
the argument against that it is designed
to limit the extent to which kids will
hear the word gay or bisexual um and as
well you know for a republican party
that supposedly supports school choice
should the government be getting
involved at all in in these kinds of
questions surely the real answer is to
say look parents should have more
control over what their kids are taught
and they should get to choose the
schools that their kids go to and what
is taught there rather than saying we do
not want you using explicit words that
understandably don't sit right with many
minority communities
well i think the republican party is
changing uh and we might not like it but
it's just the direction it's heading in
uh it is heading towards picking these
sites
and it's heading towards winning these
fights and even once it's won these
fights it will go further and win some
more
just to humiliate its enemies and it's
ugly and it's nasty
uh but it seems to be what works and
it's what
people on the right think has happened
to them for a long time and that maybe
because they have a victim complex or
something like that but it for a lot of
republican voters
uh it seems to be
uh the way to win
and they like it they like the pain that
it caused and it seems to be
particularly the social media now it
seems to be the way in which you conduct
politics
is not through
uh respecting the institution the limits
the separations of whatever powers
it's through
making your enemies suffer
and that's what ron desantis has done
and we have to say brilliantly and in
going further than he perhaps should
have done
uh from a sort of a
traditional conservative point of view
he also beautifully exposed
how the left feel about taxes because
every single
progressive american commentator started
bleating
about
government overreach into taxation and
how and seem to be
an enemy
of governments uh taking some power back
from corporations
um on taxation and that shows
to a lot of repub to a lot of republican
voters that they are not sincere when
they oppose evil corporations it's just
the evil corporations that that aren't
on their side that they oppose
so it is it's clever politics even if we
don't like it and it works charlie we
are living in strange times where you
have the progressive left defending a
corporation like disney which in many
other circumstances you would expect to
see them shouting about and you have one
of the most famous republicans right now
tipped um certainly uh to be a contender
for the next presidential election uh to
be using the powers of the state to
crack down on a company that has said
things that this particular politician
doesn't like
yeah um
before i get to that i would just
provide a quick counter argument to your
point about charter schools or you know
government setting school curricula i
mean i'm a big advocate of charter
schools florida's increased its charter
school cash by quite a lot in the last
four years um but you know public
schools are going to set curricula i
mean they are going to be set by voters
they're either going to be set at the
state level or they're going to be said
at the school board level
um
we can't escape that and so after a
certain point it becomes what the
curriculum should be whether it's good
or bad whether this move is
uh favorable or unfavorable i i don't
think you could have every charter
school in the world but as long as you
have some public school system that
that's going to come up um
on the on the disney side though it's
not necessarily going to come up
um
so the the argument that that disney uh
would make is that uh it is being
retaliated against
and that under the first amendment to
the u.s constitution that is illegal
there are a number of supreme court
cases over the years
that have held that even
contracts that don't have to be offered
even tax breaks that don't have to be
offered even special statuses that don't
have to be offered are subject to first
amendment review
um there's a famous case from 1996 in
which a guy who owned a truck company
um i believe in chicago was denied the
renewal of his contract because he had
favored um the opposing party uh in the
election and so when the guy who
actually one came in he said right we're
not renewing your contract and the
supreme court said well you can't do
that i'm not sure that was right as the
decision that the dissent from scalia
and clarence thomas is pretty good um
but that is the law
and so disney would say look you cannot
discriminate against us if it is obvious
that you're doing it for political
reasons what florida would say is well
no this isn't really retaliating we
haven't raised your tax rate or shut you
down or you know sent tanks in what
we've done here is declined to renew a
special perk that you get because it's
no longer in the public interest i don't
know how that would work out in the
courts
i think it would be a very interesting
case to watch
i just think that it is so abundantly
obvious that what has happened here is
that desantis has become angry with
disney for saying it's going to overturn
or this law or have it fought in the
courts
and then he has picked on a weakness
that disney has in the government system
i mean again no one mentioned this until
a few days ago um it's true that disney
doesn't have a right to its special
district but it didn't have a right to
its special district when it was created
in 1967 or in the 70s 80s 90s 2000 2010
until now it's never had a right to it
and no one has ever thought that it was
a bad idea this is not some issue that
comes up at cocktail parties in florida
so you know even if desantis can get
away with this legally which maybe he
can i don't know um this is a really bad
precedent to set in in my view um and
and it's something you would much more
associate with progressives who try to
do this all the time it's another form
of cancellation i suppose uh freddie you
spoke before about the emergence of a
new republican party
one that i would argue reflects more of
the donald trump style which desantis
seems to be tapping into again
potentially indicating some hope of
presidential uh presidential ambitions
there
what does it mean for the republican
party if someone like ron desantis is is
uh representative of what it now
believes
well uh i didn't know entirely what it
means i think
you know trump was this aberration and
uh has been said many times before the
party is now dominated
by the trumpet movement it isn't
entirely dominated by the trumpet
movement and politicians have to be
clever they can't just ape trump but
desantis did ape trump but it's a sort
of cleverer version in many ways and and
what i say in the piece is that
almost the art of trump and perhaps it
was the cleverest part of trump but i
don't think so is it you you always had
this sense he didn't really know what he
was doing you were never sure whether he
had any idea what he was doing with
desantis i think you feel he does know
what he's doing he's very deliberately
picking these fights
he's he's
trolling his enemies and then he's
making them suffer and
people like it it's a form of politics
that the republican party is getting
quite good at
uh picking fights with with woke
corporations or whatever it is work
institutions major league baseball in in
georgia
uh and proving itself to be on the side
of the majority
and then uh making
corporations backtrack and that they're
not bad at it and it's not a bad way of
winning
support and elections again i stress
it's not
it's not how politics perhaps should be
done but i think it's where we're going
and it seems charlie we've been going
there for some time what do you make of
all of this it is disheartening to say
the least
to
conservatives and i think small liberals
as well to see
that the republican party now is
embracing using the state and using it
in a pretty aggressive way when it suits
them
i think one of trump's arguments during
his time in office is that the left have
been doing this for some time so the
right may as well do it too but now you
have the two major parties in the states
happy to use government um to forward
its own agenda um and
i guess people who are you know in a
political tribe will feel like they're
benefiting from that from time to time
but do you think the average american
voter is going to benefit from that
overall
well i don't think anyone will benefit
if this descends into some hobbsian
fight of
all against all no um i i i would put
descendants in context here and say
i am not usually invited on
tv shows or podcasts um to criticize him
and and one of the reasons for that is
that
although
superficially desantis has exhibited
some
trump characteristics most notably his
bellicosity and willingness to to call
out journalists or um to to give press
conferences where he is
um blunt
he has been in
the mainstream of historical modern
american conservatism as governor of
florida the guy started as a tea party
um
uh guy
and uh then he was in the house freedom
caucus in congress
and as governor of florida
he's been
you know a low tax low regulation mostly
business friendly
anti-illegal immigration pro-immigrant
um
you know mainstream republican governor
who is pro-life and believes in school
choice
um
and you know this is the first moment
where he has taken off the gloves and
actually done something outside of that
mold
um
so we ought to be careful not not to
cast him as too much of a a trump figure
um
because he's not but
i think what worries me about this and
what should worry americans about this
is that this was ill thought through
i i don't necessarily think it will hurt
him and i take uh freddie's point about
this being sometimes an effective tactic
but one of the things that i have liked
about ron desantis as the governor of
florida is that he's been
thoughtful and well read you know with
covered the the left portrayed him as
this wild-eyed ideologue who was
pretending that covert didn't matter
it's just not true um in fact if you
watch interviews uh with desantis you'll
see he's read all the medical literature
he knew the statistics he knew the names
of the drugs and what they did and what
the clinical trials had said you might
dislike his conclusions
but he wasn't trump talking about you
know injecting bleach
into your skin
and
everything he's done even the moves that
i haven't agreed with seems to have been
considered and i don't think this was
and you know already we're seeing
lawyers tax experts accountants um come
out and say uh this is a an intractable
is going to be struck down he's created
a real headache for himself and so on
and so forth that's the trumpy bit you
know we all watched trump for four years
he would just say anything
um
and and that side of this alarms me
because it seems to me that a bit like
joe biden has done from the other side
desantis got carried away and forgot
that twitter is not the real world and
the pleasing people on twitter often
doesn't translate particularly well into
public policy but charlie if i if i made
it's not it's not the first time he's
sort of uh overreached conspicuously is
it i mean there was that anti-riot bill
uh you'll know more about this than me
but he he wanted to put in or he seemed
to want to put in provisions suggesting
that
drivers could could run their cars into
protesters uh if the riot was you know
they could they would have civil
immunity i think and then that
people could face racketeering charges
if the organizers of peaceful protest uh
if that protest turned violent
these these bits had got taken out of
the bill so he had to backtrack
but of course in doing so
even when he loses he wins which again
with disney could be the same thing
because fundamentally what voters care
about
is uh their children a lot of voters
with children care about their children
and the vast majority are with him not
disney on this so even if he fails
tactically he wins on the issue that's
the last question i wanted to put to
both of you in desantis versus disney
who do you think has won freddy
desantis i think
charlie well i mean i think in terms of
the public perception of it desantis
will win um and and part of the reason
for that is that disney is opposing a
bill that is popular and got caught you
know
uh its employees got caught on on video
saying insane things which is the other
part of this
um i think in desantis v disney as a
legal matter as a public policy matter
in florida i think disney will prevail
because this was ill thought through
freddie and charlie thanks for joining
me
and finally i've written for this week's
magazine about how i've been an
arachnophobe my whole life tired of
being so frightened by even a photo of a
spider i decided to undergo the london
zoo's friendly spider program which
boasts being able to reduce or even
eliminate one's fear of spiders in just
one afternoon and i'm joined now by dave
clark the head keeper of invertebrates
at the zoo and the friendly spider
program course leader who i did the
course with just a few weeks ago
dave thanks for joining me on spectator
tv and i have to say it's nice to see
you here because we last met a few weeks
ago and you met me on probably one of
the most vulnerable and nerve-wracking
days i can say i've had in a very very
long time
i came to the london zoo to take part in
the friendly spider program and in the
course of an afternoon
i know that there are lots of different
techniques you use but frankly i think
it's magic because a lifelong
arachnophobe who ranked her fear at a
ten
managed to catch a house spider by the
end of the day
well well done for a start because we're
very proud of all the people who go
through our course and we know it's not
easy and you're quite right it's very
stressful and intense to do it uh also
to build yourself up to do it um but
we're very proud of people facing their
fears and coming onto the course well
dave tell me a bit about the course
because you've been running it for many
years now i had to take a pause during
the pandemic the course i did was
actually the first one back since the
pandemic hit
there are about 40 of us
and your success rate is something like
90 percent how do you make that happen
well it's a combination of techniques
that's the main thing so the two key
ones are cognitive therapy so it's
knowledge about spiders and hypnosis and
the hypnosis helps us do it within the
course of one afternoon so as you know
it was within about three four hours uh
we've been able to turn people from
sometimes lifelong arachnophobes into
people who can cope and hopefully in
some cases well done uh to get them to
actually love spiders as well i don't
know if we were there with you yet
but that's that that's certainly
something that i prefer to try and do
with people as well um so what it starts
with um knowledge about the phobia
itself what is it that sets you off what
what where when why basically uh and
then
that comes from our hypnotherapist john
clifford uh and then i
kind of answer those questions from a
spider expert's point of view of whether
they can or can't do these things and
what the science is basically behind
behind those things that happen so why
are they coming inside the house for
example uh are they really dangerous uh
all those things uh and then we have a
short tea break which is actually quite
important um group therapy as well these
things that's particularly why we
couldn't do it during the uh pandemic
because we it's a close contact thing
really with everybody working together
on this
and then we have a short hypnosis
session which is vitally important
and then we go over to our spider
exhibit in with the spiders inside uh
london zoo and uh you get to meet the
spiders so find out whether you've got
over your fear and as you know everybody
on that course managed to get their
certificate for catching up a house
spider so it was 100 was a lovely start
to the year for us it was incredible
because there were people at the start
of the course who were crying who were
sitting in their seats during the
lecture in tears and then they were not
just cows catching house spiders they
were holding a friendly mexican red knee
which which we'll come on to um but i
wanted to hear a bit from you about the
group dynamic because i remember you
telling me at the start of the program
that you did offer individual sessions
but they often weren't as successful
that the group mattered and i could
almost immediately see why because one
of my favorite parts of the program was
us all yelling out what we disliked
about spiders there was an immediate
camaraderie that was building up and by
the time we got to the tiny giants
exhibition there were deep friendships
with people whose names i didn't know
people saying to me you know if i see
you do it maybe i can do it and me
saying gosh if i watch you do that maybe
i can do that and i i could tell that
perhaps i would have been much more
fearful and less willing to put myself
forward if i hadn't been in that group
dynamic
yeah i'm glad you picked up on that
because it is a very important part of
the course so um in the past and we have
been doing this course since 1993.
uh we've done the odd single treatment
but you're right uh at all small groups
and and it's never as successful as
doing a big group at once and and there
is a a maximum number as well i mean we
we never normally go over say 50 people
um because it sounds like a lot um but
you're right there is that that bonding
between people and we do we do encourage
everybody to have a spider buddy for the
afternoon
and they're the ones that you initially
share your experiences with and it is it
is a a a very valuable part of the way
in which we do it and um and like i said
that tea break's important because
that's the chance for everybody to sort
of relax a little bit just amongst
yourselves me and my colleague jamie who
are the spider people are are there to
answer any tech technical questions but
generally everybody's just having a chat
and sort of seeing how they're getting
on
so i'm gonna warn viewers now that if
you were like me a few weeks ago and
couldn't even see a spider a photo a
video anything without freaking out uh
you are gonna start to see some photos
pop up um including one of me holding
carol the friendly mexican red knee who
i guess would crassly be known as a
tarantula
and dave has also brought a smaller but
significant friend um who i had to catch
in order to get my certificate um
dave you brought a house spider with you
so we'll we'll pull her up and i
amazingly don't think i'm gonna scream
there she is there she is
so that's a good size
um
and
this is the typical spider that
everybody's gotta be able to deal with
when they are at home
uh so the the redness spider you
mentioned the tarantula spider as it
were uh that's sort of icing on the cake
and just a bit of where those big
spiders are actually
it's possible to hold one in your hand
they'll just sit there whereas these
little house spiders we we demonstrated
to you didn't we that actually they
don't want to come on our hands they can
sense the heat from our hands and so
we'll avoid human contact and uh
we are very careful with the spiders by
the way we think of their welfare as
well uh they get lots of downtime after
doing the uh friendly spider course uh
and some of them are released back into
the wild afterwards as well um but this
is just this little thing
sorry it was very clear that no spider
was harmed during the program um they
were nice participants um but it was
really interesting to me that you i mean
i'm gonna be completely honest dave and
i i know this is going to upset you and
upset you during the course when you
originally asked us how we usually deal
with them almost everybody admitted that
it ends in death it's either your death
or theirs and and you know you kill the
spider you take the shoe you hit it and
um by the time we got to catching this
of course just to reiterate it's never
going to be your day it's never going to
be yours because that's what you learned
as we learned in the course spiders
aren't going to harm you but that's how
you feel right you feel like it's a
fight to the death um and i have to give
you guys
by the time i was catching the house
spider i'm i'm gonna level with you i
didn't think it was cute i don't think
it's pretty it still kind of grosses me
out but as i was catching it i felt bad
for the medium-sized guy i mean they're
not how spiders aren't small but you
something had changed i i kind of knew
what the power dynamic was now and it
was it allowed me to catch it in a safe
way for the spider and also to not
result in you know a full-blown panic
attack
great that's really good and we often
name the spiders during that course of i
think there was a male called george who
was there uh on the evening and that
helps people empathize with them as
individual living creatures as well um
but a big part of people's fear or or
misunderstanding let's call it of
spiders is that they they seem so alien
and different to us but they are just
another species of animal as much as we
are and uh and and deserve uh respect as
much as anything else uh they're just
really different and um and as i may
have said during the course to me that's
what makes them fascinating that they're
different uh and we do embrace
diversity much more these days as humans
and so we should embrace animal
diversity as well
well i'm never going to forget carol's
name the uh tarantula and um i was
really terrified we took it very slow i
remember petting her back leg and you
said how does it feel and i said
horrible and you said no okay honestly
how does it feel and i have to admit it
was very silky soft and the experience
ended up being a really positive one so
dave i owe you a lot thank you uh for
helping me to downgrade my fear from
about a ten to a five um and i mean i
would highly recommend the course so um
i hope you're able to cure a lot more
arachnophobes in the near future
great thank you and uh yeah we do take
records of uh what people's fear levels
were before and after the course and i
can tell you that the average on that
course was going from an eight to a four
so we are
we are on average halving someone's fear
of spiders and uh and once we have
someone under a level of five we
consider that they're not really phobic
anymore so uh we're actually putting
together a lot of this data for a uh
paper very soon oh fantastic well look
out for that well dave thanks for
joining me
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode thanks for watching and
do join us again next week
[Music]
you